hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about
Pimsleur Pimsleur is a very respected
name in the field of language learning
there are many many people who swear by
Pimsleur as an excellent way to learn
the reason I'm talking about Pimsleur is
because I was in YouTube and I noticed
on the right hand side where they
recommend the videos on related subjects
that there was a video they're called
revealed the secret to learning a
language in 10 days so I thought wow
learn a language in 10 days I wonder
what the secret is it turns out that
it's a promotional video for Pimsleur so
I'm gonna talk a bit about this
promotional video and I will leave a
link on this video of mine so that you
can check it out if you want to first
let me say that I all bene an apology
because Benny is very modest in his
claims compared to Pimsleur Pistor
claims that in 10 days you'll speak like
a native more or less that's what they
say they claim that the secret there are
10 secrets to their great system first
of all is that it's the first thing is
that it's all audio now audio is
convenient but personally I also like to
read however they claim that you know we
were listening and speaking long before
we were reading and therefore it's
better to learn entirely via audio
without any reading that the reading
interferes with the learning I don't
agree with that for me the reading helps
me immensely right from the beginning
the second thing is that they only offer
you one less than a day now why that's a
plus I if I want to do three lessons a
day I'll do three lessons a day
the third thing they say is you can do
it anywhere anytime that's obviously
true any audio based system has this
tremendous advantage that you can do it
while doing other chores that's why I
spent 70 or more percent of my language
learning time just plain listening the
fourth point they say is that Pimsleur
is fun
I mean Pimsleur is is in a sense easy
and then just sit back and listen I've
done it I didn't find it fun I'm not I
know a lot of people like him sir I'm
not sure they find it fun a lot of the
dialogue is pretty boring the fifth
point they make is that they focus on
the most common words and phrases I'm
not a great believer in this great
emphasis on the most common words and
phrases I find the most common words and
phrases well because they are the most
common and they'll show up all the time
no matter what content you're working
with but that ultimately if your goal is
to be able to speak on a variety of
subjects you need a lot of words the
bigger biggest I would say that this
advantage of Pimsleur is that you learn
so few words sixth advantage they claim
is that there's no rote memory which is
fine that you learn things naturally and
I think this is true if you spend a lot
of time let's think you're gonna start
picking up on things
however they they basically say
flashcards don't work I find that
flashcards and a number of other parts
of the traditional teaching methodology
are things that help you notice
including reviewing the out grammar rule
certainly they get a general sense of
the language to start with and then
later on from time to time to help you
notice things that you just won't notice
otherwise the seventh thing they say is
that the way they teach you can learn to
speak without an accent people will
mistake you for a native that's simply
nonsense in ten days of this system you
are not going to sound like a native my
own preference in fact is to wait until
I've had enough exposure to the language
before I even start to pronounce the
language but that's individual it
depends on your personal goals it
depends on where you are if you're
located where the language is spoken you
have to get cracking speaking the
language more quickly the eighth thing
they mention is that they've done 80
years of 50 sorry 50 years of research I
don't believe they've been doing any
meaningful research for 50 years I think
they have a system which they
occasionally modify then they
they say the nice thing is that by this
natural method of learning you will
naturally be able to tell what's right
in what isn't right what sounds right
without reference to rules true I think
that we should rely on our ability to
notice what's right because we've heard
it so often because we've noticed it
with them number of things to become
aware of the language and therefore we
don't have to remember the rule but the
rule has a role in my view as helping
you notice things but once you've
noticed it then you forget the rule it's
a bit like the Taoists you know drums
are said you know use a fish net to
catch a fish and once you cut the fish
you throw away the net or words to that
effect
um the tenth thing they say is that the
program is aimed for adults and that
adults learn more quickly than children
I think when it comes to a limited
amount of content children learn faster
than adults because they are less
inhibited because their brains are more
flexible when it comes to acquiring a
lot of vocabulary which is my goal in
language learning
then adults can do a better job because
they have more life experience more
vocabulary in their own language and
then this video sort of stresses the
four secrets to pincers success the
first one is a thing called graduated
interval recall which is simply another
way of saying spaced repetition and they
designed their dialogues such that
certain words and phrases regularly
reoccur which is fine as far as it goes
but my bigger concern with them is that
there's just so little in the way of
vocabulary that you can learn in their
system the second secret to their
success is what they call anticipation
rather than just repetition and I think
they feel that by prompting you in
English to say things in Russian they
are training you to anticipate I don't
agree
I find it unpleasant to have to you know
respond to these prompts especially as a
beginner when I can't do them I believe
that based on the little reading I've
done on on
the brain works and especially the
function of our mirror neurons that as
we get more and more exposure to the
language our ability to anticipate
improves and that I gather that if we
are used to listening to a language
Russian Chinese whatever and we've been
doing a variety of things to help us
notice the language that when we hear it
the neurons fire the same way as if we
were speaking so I have never felt that
there was a great need to start speaking
early I think speaking is a good thing
to do and the amount of speaking should
increase and when we speak we do
discover gaps in our learning so it's
one of these things like flashcard
review like grammar review one of these
things that helped us notice things but
in my way of learning is those of you
who have listened to me before know very
well still focuses largely on input
listening and reading the third thing
they say that's their secret is that
it's organic in other words it's
listening only and they make a big deal
of the fact that human beings were
listening before they were reading true
and so listening is important but I find
it much easier to learn if I can also
read I find that all of these things
help us notice things it helps to make
the vocabulary stick so why would I deny
myself reading and in fact I listen when
I'm doing other chores but if I have
dedicated learning time available I
prefer to read because I believe that my
vocabulary grows more when I read when I
can actually see the word and when we're
learning a language when we read we
always sub vocalize anyway so it's kind
of somewhat almost like listening
assisted listening the fourth thing
again their secret is this core
vocabulary idea which is again very
common people are very concerned to
learn the most common words and if we
are prepared to - it depends on our
goals if we only want to be able to say
a few things
order food
then perhaps one can focus on on those
words but I find that no matter what
situation you're in whether you're
ordering food in a restaurant whether
you're in a store that in fact you need
a lot more vocabulary than this
pre-selected you know vocabulary to use
in different situations
it never is quite enough so to me as
I've said many times language learning
is primarily about learning words lots
of words so that I will necessarily find
the more common words and you know a
link for example I can search by the
most frequent words so that in my review
in my flashcard review I will focus on
the most frequent words and that'll
naturally select out in the system but
in my reading and listening I'm
motivated to get to interesting content
as soon as possible I want to get away
from the kind of dialogue that you get
at in Pimsleur I want to get away from
that as soon as possible the other thing
I guess oh yes pimp stir then they slam
rosetta stone and and say that it's
impractical because people who work all
day don't want to sit at the computer at
night true to some extent and it's
certainly true that learning with an
ipod is very much more portable however
lots of people do spend their own time
in front of a computer otherwise
Facebook wouldn't be so popular now the
this you should watch the video they
offer a guarantee if you're not
proficient after 30 days or within 30
days and the big thing is they're
selling their a package for ten dollars
which strikes me as pretty cheap
personally today if I were I went today
I had I was in the car so I threw on
pimps turd Rushton just to hear it again
and if I were to use it today I would
use it not as beginner material but as
material to sort of refresh some of the
basics and also insofar as Raj is
concerned and for Chuck I might use it
to help me speak more in other words
having now accumulated a lot of
vocabulary in check
having spoken very little and having a
lot of trouble speaking but I can read a
book on history it might be that
Pimsleur might help me speak but I'm not
sure I think if I sit in the car I would
rather listen to my check audio book or
check radio you know programs and then
struggle in my online conversation with
our tutors at link rather than listening
to Templar however I say all of that but
I want to stress that there are a lot of
people who swear by Pam Stern who have
been helped a great deal by penciler so
it's very much a matter of your learning
style and your learning goals but I was
quite taken aback by these basic
hucksterism of pimp slurs message where
they tell you that they have learned the
secret they have or they're gonna offer
you the secret to learning a language in
ten days and that you'll sound like a
native that just ain't gonna be that
case anyway look forward to your
comments thank you for listening